you're not here we're not there the car
exploded
come get the girls I have to stay here
with Woodrow another chauffeur I'm the
grandfather where are you asteroid City
farm Route 6 Mile 75.
the star gazers and Space Cadets
each year we set up story day
commemorating September 23rd 3007 BC
when the Arid Plains meteorite made
Earth impact
Toledo that's Mitch Campbell you're very
good in the one about the in the
brothel who gets amnesian making a
pediatrician you're very honestly maybe
my favorite character ever I don't know
why nobody else liked it
what do those pulses indicate what oh
the beeps and blips we don't know some
of our information about outer space May
no longer be completely accurate anyway
there's still only nine planets in the
solar system as far as we know Billy
except now there's an alien
I don't know
I don't like the way that guy looked at
us the alien how did he look like we're
doomed
maybe we are I've just informed the
president how long can they keep us an
asteroid City legally the world will
never be the same that's alien doing
jumping jacks that's an alienator Top
Hat what's out there the meaning of life
maybe there is one are you married I'm a
widower but don't tell my kids you're
saying her mother died three weeks ago
let's say she's in heaven which doesn't
exist for me of course but you're
Episcopalian in my loneliness I learned
to give complete and unquestioning Faith
to the people I love I don't know if
that includes you but it included my
daughter and your four children
sometimes I think I feel more at home
outside the Earth's atmosphere oh wow
me too they're strange aren't they
they're children
compared to normal people yes that's
correct that's true
going so fast
I do a nude scene you want to see it
[Music]
did I say yes you didn't say anything I
meant yes my mouth didn't speak